ehi di cote proprio a te che stai
aprendo il dito nella speranza di veder
micri stonare se una cattiva persona è
da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo io sono la vj ed oggi son
supermario ragazzi io lo scorso episodio
lo chiuso malissimo perché veramente
stavo uscendo di testa voi non avete
idea non avete idea è che aspettate che
inizi questo episodio non seriamente
solo morto è [ __ ] sono morto 250
mila volte nello stesso identico modo
nello scorso episodio poi non avete idea
dello sclero allora amici miei abbiamo
intenzione di andare avanti qui mi sa di
no ragazzi visto che ho trovato un nuovo
anti stress vi piace e funziona più di
cat mario cazzola aspettate un attimo
spider man di fano chicca ragazzi devo
superare sforzo devo arrivare all'altro
morto non è difficile ma [ __ ] da
dacca da vent anni 80 la retata data di
avvio
noe kat ho fatto lo so adesso io non ho
la più pallida idea di dove siano le
trappole io pazzo piano di sotto
superando lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo milioni
[Musica]
io no no no porca [ __ ] ce lo sto
facendo lezione è colpa tua ma le forche
appunto no dai ragazzi cioè 399 morti in
totale ma che cazzo mi state facendo
giocare non l'edizione non è posto io
non è più non ci posso credere
ragazzi sto gioco inguardabile abbiate
pazienza io vengono fatti non sono
vecchio che cosa ho fatto ma va bene
così va bene così piano piano
io mio sì non ci posso credere cazzo me
e mezz'ora per fare mezz'ora era il
primo livello di oggi mezz'ora e siamo
arrivati al primo checkpoint marca tra i
ragazzi non si può fare sto gioco è
impossibile che io voglio sapere chi
l'ha inventato perché non musto nike e
che cazzo fatto ma stavo finendo il
livello a un tentativo non si sa come si
si si non ci credo ragazzi ho fatto una
cosa è mica ad avere sempre facile
ragazzi non mi sembra tanto di bici
adesso io provo non so e magari se i
ministri si ok meglio salti in cda ok ok
ok perfetto mega salt una sega
adesso arriva al casinò meno perché una
volta che seguì non sai ke kazzo fare
unitevi a me e soffrite insieme a me
ragazzi oppure gli spara cazzate già
arriva ai tuoi guardi non ci credo non
so come cazzo abbiamo fatto nell'angolo
in alto a sinistra dello schermo
possiamo notare un esemplare di fa vj
alquanto sorpreso ma quanto mai potrà
durare ragazzi bastano già faccio più
isolato se ho preso check point cazzo
almeno quello se ce l'ho fatta
avete opponendo ragazzi che sto gioco mi
fa infatti abbastanza ma io riesco io ci
riesco io dio mio dio mio dio
ancora lui ancora lui
tutto è stato detto tutto
non ci faccio il credo del cazzo ok
stavolta non mi fatti stronzo
stavolta pazzo al problema gari da
ragazzi privo di sopra poi [ __ ]
non era il primo era di sottomisura
bagnato scusate ok ok ok una sega
ragazzino seriamente come chiamano fatta
tra passare come faccio a trapassare i
pugni perché lì tra bussi salame non
importa vai e vai a mamma ce la posso
fare
dio mio che cazzo succede liberami di
quel lontano nave brutto stronzo ti
denuncio ti denuncio divenuto affanculo
polizia quel pollo di gomma che li
stacco legame già sto facendo io non ci
credo
per lui che mario passò sotto poi salta
sopra si destreggia si destreggia
incredibile ragazzi va ancora avanti o
fenomeno è un fenomeno cazzo è un
fenomeno una tartaruga e non si sta
facendo le pippe ma lui continua ri
continua si adatta a tutti tutti cazzo
non ci credo non ci voglio credere
ragazzi non ci credo ragazzi sto livello
infattibile comunque c'è una cosa
impressionante non so come un essere
umano possa fare sta roba ma io ci provo
ci provo lo stesso ci provo perché ci
credo
si no
[Musica]
il ragazzo dai cazzo dai dai dai
no cosa 4 con tute ore di livello non ci
posso credere non ci posso credere
ragazzi non so come ho fatto è una cosa
impossibile impossibile ho passato le 4
ore peggiori si metta la mia tuta vita
maledizione ragazzi sto livelli più
infattibile di quello di prima ma si può
mio figlio si può fare se non si può
passare lì in mezzo c'è spiegatemi come
dovrei fare a passare lì in mezzo come
come cosa
[Musica]
tutto finito
ragazzi siamo arrivati a livello finale
dopo tutti sti casini devo finire sto
gioco di merda devo farcela devo fare
ormai una questione di vita o di morte
non me ne frega più in carceri non dormo
più finché non finisco sta merda
devo farcela [ __ ]
sì sì sì
roma di regata era l'ultimo livello
posso finalmente smetterla di prendere
tranquillanti ancora per poco perché la
settimana prossima inizia una nuova ray
g game ha concluso più l'episodio perché
veramente non ne posso più voi non avete
idea di quante cazzo di volte io ci
abbia provato
se pensate che le mie incazzature siano
servite a qualcosa mettetevi piace non
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook e
come non i video trovate nella
descrizione sempre per iscritti
iscrivetevi ci rivediamo un prossimo
vito bene ragazzi